PROFESSOR: So today
we're going to take
a look at sinusoidal functions.
And specifically, we're
going to use complex numbers
to get a handle on
sinusoidal functions.
The reason is complex
numbers provide
a robust way of analyzing
sinusoidal functions.
So specifically, we're
interested in this function,
e to the i*omega*t
divided by 2 plus 3i.
And we're asked to
write the real part
of this function using polar
form and then rectangular form.
And then secondly, we're
asked several properties
of this function, the real
part of this function.
What's the circular frequency?
What's the amplitude?
And what's the phase lag?
And then lastly, we're asked
to sketch the real part
of this function versus time.
So I'll let you take a look at
this and try it for yourself.
And I'll come back in a moment.
Hi everyone.
Welcome back.
OK.
So let's take a look
at this problem.
So we're asked to write e to
i*omega*t divided by 2 plus 3i.
We're asked to write the
real part of this function,
using polar form and then
also rectangular form.
So I'll first start
off with polar form.
And if we take a look
at this function,
we see that the numerator is
already written in polar form.
So just recall that polar
form is of the form r e
to the i*theta.
Meanwhile, the denominator
is written in Cartesian form,
or rectangular form.
So we need to convert
this into polar form.
So what we can do is
we can write 2 plus 3i.
We can combine these
two into a modulus.
And the modulus is going
to be the square root of 2
squared plus 3 squared.
So this is the modulus
of the complex number.
And then we have e to the i*phi.
And the angle phi we can deduce
by writing a triangle, which
is over to the
right by two units,
and then it's up two units.
And this is the angle phi.
So we see from the triangle
that the tangent of phi
is equal to 3/2.
OK.
So putting the pieces together,
we have e to the i*omega*t
divided by root 13 e to i*phi.
And the beautiful
thing about polar form
is that when we
divide and multiply
these complex
exponentials, it just
turns into a simple addition
or subtraction of the phases.
So we have 1 over root 13, e
to the i*omega*t minus phi.
So we've successfully
combined all the terms
into one polar term.
And then now we're asked
to compute the real part.
And here we use Euler's formula.
So just to recall
Euler's formula,
we have e to the i theta.
Then this is equal to cosine
theta plus i sine theta.
OK?
So at the end of the day, we're
interested in the real part--
and I'm going to
use this notation Re
with a curly bracket to
denote the real part-- of 1
over root 13.
And I'll use Euler's formula on
e to the i*omega*t minus phi.
So we have cosine omega*t minus
phi plus i sine omega*t minus
phi.
Sorry.
1 over root 13 is multiplying
both the sine and the cosine.
And we see that the second
term is purely imaginary.
So when we take the real
part of a real number
plus an imaginary
number, we just
are left with the real
number at the end of the day.
So the answer we're looking
for is 1 over root 13 cosine
omega*t minus phi, where from
before phi is the arctangent
of 3/2.
And phi can also be thought
of-- the angle being
between zero and pi over 2.
OK.
So this concludes the
polar form computation.
Secondly, we also have
to compute this using
a rectangular form calculation.
So let's do the calculation
in rectangular form.
And for this, I'm going
to use Euler's formula
to expand out the numerator.
So first, we want to take the
real part of the numerator is
cosine omega*T plus
i sine omega*t.
The denominator was 2 plus 3i.
And typically what
we want to do is
we want to turn the denominator
into an entirely real number.
So what we do is we
multiply the top and bottom
by the complex conjugate
of the denominator.
So for example,
I have 2 plus 3i.
So I'm going to multiply the
top and bottom by 2 minus 3i.
OK.
And when I do this, you'll
note that when we multiply out
2 plus 3i and 2 minus 3i we
have a difference of squares.
So we're left with: 2 times 2
is 4, the cross terms cancel.
And then we have 3i
times negative 3i.
That's going to give us negative
9 i squared, which is plus 9.
So the denominator is
going to be 4 plus 9.
And then the numerator-- I'll
write out all the terms just
for completeness-- it'll be
2 times cosine omega*t plus 3
sine omega*t.
And then now we have
some imaginary terms,
which are negative 3 cosine
omega*t and plus 2 sine
omega*t.
OK?
But now we're going
to take the real part
of this complex function.
And if we take a look
at it, this first term
is entirely real.
This second term
is entirely complex
because we're
multiplying by an i.
So when we take the real
part, at the end of the day,
the second term is
going to drop out.
So when the dust settles,
we have 1/13 2 times cosine
omega*t plus 3 sine omega*t.
OK?
So this concludes Part A.
For Part B, we're
asked several questions
about this sinusoidal function
when written in its real form,
specifically, what's
the circular frequency.
And the circular frequency
is just the frequency
that this function
oscillates at.
And we can get this from
looking at the rectangular form
or the polar form.
And it's simply just
going to be omega.
So note how this
function oscillates
with frequency omega.
Secondly, we're asked
about the amplitude.
And if we take a look
at it, the amplitude
is a little tricky to get
from the rectangular form,
but it's completely apparent
from the polar form.
So if we take a look
at the polar form,
we have 1 over root 13
cosine omega*t minus phi.
And cosine oscillates
between plus 1 and minus 1.
So this function takes
on a maximum value
of plus 1 over root 13 and
a maximum negative value
of negative 1 over root 13.
So the amplitude
of this function
is just going to
be 1 over root 13.
And then lastly, the phase lag.
This is the angle
that the cosine
is picked up and shifted over.
So again, we can get this
directly from the polar form.
Meanwhile, it's a
little less obvious
what this angle is when we take
a look at the rectangular form.
So in our case, the
phase lag is just
going to be phi, which
is tan inverse 3/2.
OK?
So this concludes Part B.
And then lastly,
for Part C we're
just asked to
sketch this diagram.
And again, the most direct
way at sketching this function
is through the polar form.
So I'll write time on this axis.
And if we just recall that a
cosine might look something
like this.
So this is a cosine function.
And in our case, we're looking
at plotting 1 over root 13
cosine omega*t minus phi.
So we're interested
in a cosine which
has an amplitude
of 1 over root 13
and a maximum negative value
of minus 1 over root 13
whose frequency is omega.
So there's a quick
way on finding zeros.
So if the zero of a regular
cosine is at pi over 2,
then if we have an angular
frequency of omega,
the zero here is going
to be pi over 2*omega.
And this zero is going to
be at 3 pi over 2*omega.
And lastly, this
is not necessarily
the cosine of our function.
Our function is this cosine.
However it must be picked
up and shifted over
by some phase lag phi.
So in our case, the function
we're actually looking for
is some shifted cosine,
which looks like this.
And this distance here
is phi over omega.
OK?
So this just gives us a quick
sketch of this function.
And again, we note that we
were able to plot this using
the polar form very quickly.
And the reason is because
the polar form gives us
the amplitude, the circular
frequency, and the phase lag.
Whereas if we were
to take a look
at the equivalent
rectangular form,
it's a little less obvious.
The rectangular form is actually
the sum of a sine and a cosine.
And unless you can just add
sines and cosines in your head
very quickly, it's a
little less obvious
on how to come up
with this picture.
OK.
So just to summarize, we've
used complex functions
to analyze sinusoidal functions.
And we've used polar
form and rectangular form
to get a handle on
the complex functions.
And specifically,
complex functions
are a very good way to
represent sinusoidal functions.
And just to
reiterate, the reason
is that they contain
a lot of information
that we can graphically
handle and turn into a sketch.
So I'll just conclude there,
and I'll see you next time.